my required script as chair of the house
judiciary committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
an accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
which is pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
some committee members are participating
in this meeting here at the legislative
office bill
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the house
judiciary committee it could be followed
by an executive session
but i've indicated that we won't hold an
executive session today
we will wait till all committee members
are available
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing
accessing the meeting should call
[Music]
271-3600-271-3600
or email hcs
leg.state.nh.u.s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
we do have a staff member member who is
also
uh on line with us here today and that's
gen
four our committee researcher please
note that all votes
that will be taken during this meeting
if any will be done by roll call vote
only we'll start the meeting by
beginning roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
mr clerk do you want to call the role i
do
i guess we might as well start with you
mr chairman
yes i am here i'm in the legislative
office building together with
uh representative mclean and
representative
representative mclean uh yes i'm here in
the llb
uh with you two fine gentlemen
representative sylvia home alone in
belmont new hampshire
representative welper is here with uh
chair and vice chair
representative alexander
representative alexander representative
rice
representative rice
representative silber
representative silver
representative greene yes i'm here at
home
and my wife is in and out representative
kelly
representative kelly
representative tosh
representative trottier i'm not here in
delaware in my office
alone representative marjorie smith
i'm out of state in a room alone
representative bird uh i am home alone
in west milan
representative oregon i am home alone in
my home office in durham
representative di lorenzo i'm in my home
office in new market and i am alone in
the room
representative chase i'm here in
rollinsford home alone
representative kenny i am here
uh in my apartment in your room
i am here home with my husband in
manchester
representative macbeth
representative page morning i'm in
exeter and my wife is in the house
representative simpson hello
i'm here in exeter alone for the moment
this is here mr chairman
thank you mr clerk we're
here to hear two bills this morning
house bill 41
house bill 143 and we'll begin
uh this morning unless there's other
business to attend to
by hearing are beginning our hearing on
house on senate bill excuse me
senate bill 41 i note that the prime
spawn and
sponsor is senator french
before we begin i just note that there
are 81 people who signed up and support
three people who signed up in opposition
and only two people indicated their
intent to testify today
and one of those was senator french but
i'm looking
senator friendship if you were among the
attendees you could raise your hand so
we could identify you
i do not see senator french
i'll yes uh representative maclean would
you
uh introduce the bill yes mr chair
for the record uh my name is uh
representative mark mclean representing
uh manchester and litchfield and i'm
here to introduce
senate bill 41 relative to
police disciplinary hearings
thank you representative clinton
the other person who did sign up to
testify is
uh attorney bissonnette to call upon him
to testify
thank you so much mr chairman can i be
heard
you can oh wonderful wonderful thank you
my name is jill
bissonnette i'm the legal director for
the aclu of new hampshire we support
uh senate bill 41 as things are
right now police decertification
hearings are
usually held in secret the public is
kept
in the dark about what happens in these
hearings and there's
no public review of the process really
unless the officer
potentially being decertified chooses to
grant
the public access and so this bill would
remedy this and create a process that's
more in line
with how disciplinary hearings are
conducted for judges and lawyers
which are public i'd also note that our
former attorney general gordon mcdonald
has also publicly declared his support
for this type of legislation stating
quote i would support a legislative
change which aligns the police standards
and training council certification
hearings
with the statutes that allow other
professional licensure boards to conduct
public hearings it's the right thing to
do
and that's end quote um lastly
i would note that the house already
heard its own version of this bill
and that was house bill 471 which was
sponsored by
representative roy and was heard before
the house criminal justice and public
safety committee
that bill came out of committee 20 to
nothing and passed
uh the house by voice vote on april 7th
just a few
weeks ago the senate judiciary committee
took this bill up
um just last week on april 15th
and uh also amended it um or potent or
not
is considering i should say an amendment
uh
uh to add to this bill that would also
address the public disclosure of the
exculpatory evidence schedule so i just
wanted to let the committee know
of that and in light of that i think my
recommendation actually would be
for this committee to actually just
retain senate bill
41 this bill and allow hb 471 to be the
vehicle
to address this issue especially where i
think actually the language
um in hb 471 is frankly just a little
bit cleaner than the language here
in sb41 so that's just my thinking
i wanted to let the committee know and
of course i'd be happy to take any
questions
are there any questions for uh attorney
bison
i guess i i did have a question
and maybe you somewhat addressed that in
your testimony and
that is with regard to the language of
the bill itself
it mentions it says that
one of the things that would have to be
shown in order to close the hearing is
that
the information is confidential but
is is confidential information defined
someplace in the statute
i guess what constitutes confidential
information
that's a great question it is actually
not defined in this statute but i think
the reason why
that language has been used is because
it's modeled
after the standards that exist
in the courts for when confidential
information is sealed and so for example
i think it's
new hampshire superior court rule of
criminal procedure
50 or 51 i believe actually has a list
of information that's uh presumptively
confidential that would allow
courts to have that information sealed
and overcome the public's
right of access and so that's um
that it's not defined in this particular
statute but it's essentially modeled
after this that's i think the intent um
as to what confidential information
would mean this is really again just
modeling the standard here is modeled
after how the courts
steal information
and i guess if i could ask another
question that was
it uses the language creates a
compelling interest
i guess the question is how do you
measure what a compelling interest is
what is compelling interest
is it harm to something
yeah so again that's actually the same
standard that exists in the court system
and it comes right out of the
uh the key the petition re-keen sentinel
case
uh from a few decades ago and i'd be
happy uh chairman to actually circulate
that
um and i think you know what that
standard is really getting at are
situations where there's you know a very
important privacy interest at play like
for example
information concerning confidential
informants that comes up sometimes in
criminal cases
and there's a really overwhelming public
interest sometimes to not have that
information be public even if it's part
of a court pleading
so i think the idea here is that in
police standards and training
decertification hearings there could be
situations
and it's hard to anticipate when and how
they would come up but there could be
situations in which there would just be
really sensitive
information in play and so what this
does is just create a mechanism for
in those rare circumstances to to have
that information be sealed but it really
should be a rare event just like it's a
rare event in court proceedings
for information to be sealed
and i had one other question and that
was
at some point in time someone has to
make a decision as to whether or not
the hearing or a portion of the hearing
should be closed
it doesn't mention in here specifically
who that is
should there be some reference to who
that
is for hearing prophecy or whatever
yes mr chairman and in fact that
actually is one reason why the language
in hb
471 might be a little better and cleaner
than the language here in senate bill
41. so
in hb 471 the house criminal justice
committee actually amended the bill to
tack on a sentence
that said the council may in a
non-public session
hear and consider the request for
closure in rule on such
such a request that language is not
actually in senate bill 41
and i think the purpose of that language
mr chairman is to get at the concern you
just raised
is that mechanically i think the way it
should work is that it's the pstc
council that's doing that pass in
deciding whether something is
confidential or not
someone shouldn't have to like you know
file up 91a action or anything like that
so that is really again designed to
model this after the court process
where it's the trial judge or the
district judge that makes the decision
whether information should be sealed and
of course that decision
should be private should happen you know
privately as well right
um in order to protect the interests of
those involved and so that's again
that's the idea behind the language of
471 and another reason why we think
you know it might be just you know
better to use that as the vehicle
yes representative burch thank you mr
chair
and thank you attorney bisonette for
taking my question my concern
is the difference between uh
the language that says any person who
has an interest
may be uh represented or part of the
proceeding
but that the only person but only a
party
can ask that the matter be closed
so let's say um
i i'm a witness and i'm part of the
proceeding
and there's a grounds where i think uh
my stuff should be uh kept
private let's say i'm a minor or
whatever
am i reading it correct that only a
party
can uh can ask for closure
you're uh you're referring to the
language of senate bill 41 itself not
471 correct
yeah we're just looking at 41 here yeah
i i think that's a good question and i
i at least the way i read it i kind of
had viewed it as it's a party to the
pstc hearing process which would be
you know either the um the psdc
officer that is essentially prosecuting
you know the
the action or the officer itself
um i don't know if i borrow it uh if i
if i construe it to bar third parties
from also
um having their interests heard but it's
a good question i don't have a great
answer for you i could just tell you
that i think in
the court process right the only folks
that
really go through the motion to seal
process or the actual parties or
litigants at least in my experience so
again i think this language really here
is just designed
to try to model this as much as possible
after the court process that we have
thank you are there any other questions
for attorney bissonnette
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
and i don't have anyone else who has
signed up to testify
are there any other persons who are in
attendance who would like to testify
if there are please raise your hand
xenon will close the hearing on senate
bill 41.
and we have a few minutes before we
begin our hearing
on 143
i note uh that on 143 we have 10 people
who have signed up
to speak there are only 14 people who
signed up and support
two in opposition and 10 people who
signed up
to speak this morning
most of whom are public officials
you if you saw my email yesterday my
intent is to call upon
senator carson first who is the sponsor
of the omnibus bill
in its entirety but she's also the
primary sponsor i think on six of the
twelve
bills six of the twelve parts that
constitute the omnibus bill
and then call upon the other senators
and then if there are any reps who would
like to speak i'll call upon them and
then
just generally open it up i considered
going part by part
but the issue with that
is if somebody we scheduled a hearing
for 9 30 if
somebody is on the 12th car i was
concerned that they might have to wait
two hours
before they get to speak and i'm not
sure that that was particularly fair
so we're just going to open it up to
anybody who wants to speak and not go
through part by part
excuse me mr chairman yes
i missed how many speakers you said
there were you mentioned it and i just
missed the number
there are 10 people who have registered
in advance to speak
great thank you
i note that six of the ten are senators
i did uh set out a schedule uh
with regard to the bills we we have six
bills
uh if you actually broke them into parts
we have about 30 bills but
the because they we have three
fairly large omnibus bills
they so and
what is planned is we meet every tuesday
for this week and the next four weeks
to hear the bills and to execute
and to get them out and which would give
us plenty of time
before we're required to get them out
there and none of the bills have to go
to a second committee
so we don't need to be concerned about
that with
rushing through any of the bills in
particular
and we have uh
two two of the hearings are just gonna
be on omnibus bills one omnibus bill
each
uh because they are very large and
complicated this bill
that we're about to hear was probably
the least complicated of the omnibus
bills i thought
and that's why i scheduled it
with with the other bill today
and we generate the least amount of
controversy
i note that the very first part of this
bill
will be familiar to everyone as it
addresses the issue of appointment for
council for
minors
and from what i'm told it looks like we
will be back for
our next full session of the legislature
in early june
the first week of june
we i did indicate in an email that
we would plan to hear bills
next week we'll hear two bills and
then after that we'll start hearing
bills and then
have executive session in the afternoons
to
rule on the bills get them out
if you know you're not going to be
available and i know
representative trotty has already let me
know he can't make one of those meetings
but if you for any reason you're not
going to be able to meet one of
be at those executive sessions make sure
you let
let us know or let your office know so
that they can provide a substitute
i was proud of the committee members at
the session the week before last i
thought people represented themselves
and the committee
well we had some really tough issues to
deal with
it was it was very interesting i thought
the uh the debate
particularly the debate of 111 was uh
interesting debating that was one of the
few debates where we had
people from both parties waiting on
either side
was maybe not the outcome that
some wanted but very
thoughtful interesting debate i thought
they thought the people in our committee
represented the committee
very well i'd like to give kudos to
representative kurtz i thought i did an
outstanding job talking about the
history of it
and uh very enlightening to me even as a
co-sponsor
but he was eloquent and should have won
so
later jack
she was on
she was on another
okay
okay we'll call the current order on
senate bill 143 fm
this is a omnibus bill
and to call upon the sponsor of the
omnibus bill
senator carson to provide her to
introduce the bill and provide her
testimony today
i note that she's also the primary
sponsor
on six portions of that bill which she
could address as well if she wishes
good morning mr chairman and good
morning members
of the house judiciary committee for the
record my name is sharon carson
and i have the pleasure of representing
senate district 14
which comprises the towns of londonderry
hudson and auburn
and i have for your consideration this
morning senate bill 143 fn
which is adopting omnibus legislation
relative to certain
agency requests um mr chairman
there are 12 parts of this bill
how would you like me to proceed
uh i would if you wanted to just go down
through the parts that would be helpful
to everyone okay um i will be more than
happy to do that
um the first part which is the
appointment of
counsel for a minor in a juvenile
delinquency proceeding
mr chairman um uh this part of the bill
part one was a refile from 2020
which was part of an omnibus bill that
had been vetoed
um okay
part two is the recovery of unauthorized
payments by the state as requested by
the department
of health and human services this part
of the bill was
filed by senator gray and it was filed
in 2020 but did not become law due to
the covet 19 pandemic um senator gray
said that rsa 167 colon
17 reflux refers to collateral resources
while rsa 167 colon 17
dash a leaves out the reference to
collateral resources
he said this has caused some problems
for the department which wants to
correct
the disparity part three of the bill
um is uh concerns alternative resolution
uh excuse me alternative dispute
resolution
this bill um was uh
filed in 2020 but died on the table in
the house
and was not in an omnibus bill and
uh let's see am i on the right part too
let's see um yes and it
authorizes the establishment of a
quality assurance program
for the office of mediation and
arbitration
part four of the bill allowing judicial
referees to issue orders in
non-contested probate matters
um again mr chairman this bill was filed
in 2020 but died on the table in the
house
and was not part of an omnibus bill and
it authorizes administrative judges to
appoint judicial referees in certain
probate matters
okay um section five
is uh allows permits a supreme court
justice to sit as a circuit court
judge um this was part of uh
this bill died on the table in 2020
and again would allow a supreme court
justice to sit as a circuit court
judge okay
part six of the bill mr chairman
is uh payment of costs for services
other than
council for indigent parties um
this bill again uh originally died on
the table in 2020
and it deals with the payment of costs
for services
other than council part seven
deals with um it again this is another
bill that was
uh died on the table in the house and
was not part of an omnibus bill
and it requires a penalty assessment for
violation offenses
mr chairman with the exception of the
first bill
all of these bills were filed at the
request of the judicial branch in 2020
part uh part eight of the bill um
is concerned cyber security incident
reporting and recommended cyber security
standards for political subdivisions
this addresses this
addresses cyber security incident
reporting and
recommended standards this bill was
originally filed by senator rosenwald
and she said it was a request of the
department of information technology
okay part nine of the bill deals with
emergency and medical trauma services
data this bill was introduced
by senator prentiss and she said
that it was a request of the department
of safety
it expands the language for what
entities department of
uh safety can share data with for the
purposes of analysis and research
she it also creates a new paragraph
allowing the department of safety to
participate in the national emergency
medical
services information system and it also
made changes to rsa 153-a
to clean up language to reflect changes
made earlier
mr chairman um senator prentice passed
on
to me some language that the department
of
safety would like to amend this part of
the bill with
um i did not have an amendment drawn up
but if you would like
me to have an amendment drawn up for the
committee i will be more than happy to
do that
and to pass it on to you uh you just let
me know what you would prefer
part 10 of the bill
deals with the appeal of a claim denied
by the victims
assistance um this bill was
filed on by senator khan
and it sets up an appeal process if a
claim was denied
first to the attorney general and then
to the supreme court
part 11 of the bill was filed by senator
gary daniels
and he said that it updates the statute
concerning
insurance licensing re applications for
compliance with the national
association of insurance commissioner
uniform standards as well as amends the
department of revenue administration
statute
to allow the sharing of information
regarding the business enterprise
tax within with the new hampshire
insurance department as to ensure the
proper premium
taxes being collected and he also said
that the insurance industry
supports uh part 11 of senate bill 143
and finally mr chairman uh part 12
this um this bill repeals the national
this part of the bill repeals the
national guard
scholarship program and replaces it with
the national guard
enlistment incentive program um
it provides a 500 incentive to current
members of the national guard
at ranks e1 through 03 as well as any
former member
for any new recruit they recommend who
enlists
and mr chairman uh section 12 of the
bill
was at the request of the uh of the
national guard uh mr chairman also if
the committee
desires um as you know as a former
member of the senate we have
hearing reports and i will be more than
happy to
forward that hearing report to you mr
chairman so you can make it available to
your members
i don't know who is going to be here to
testify
on this this morning but hopefully
having that hearing report
will help your members um
get additional information that
hopefully that
they can take a look at and will allow
them to pass this
bill so at this point mr chairman i will
conclude my testimony
um and i don't i don't think i
i i will try to answer questions but
again
hopefully folks are going to be here to
talk about
their section of the bill thank you mr
chairman
thank you senator representative did you
have a question
yes i do thank you thank you senator
um so i have a couple of questions
because there's
different parts to this and i i don't
know if you can answer them
or not but i was looking for the fiscal
note on part one because
we had this uh a bill similar to this
in the house and i know that the courts
wanted a fiscal note on it because they
were concerned about
costs and not you know having the money
to cover this
uh thank you thank you very much um for
your testimony
the only fiscal note that we received
was
the um
was what came with originally with the
bill so
that's all we have we don't have
anything else
um this fiscal note it was dated
uh 2 4 21 we did not get an updated
version
okay thank you follow up mr chairman
um another concern we had with the
appointment of council and juvenile
cases
is is this going to follow the child
through civil cases
i'm sorry i didn't quite catch the
question um
would would the attorney follow this
child if the if a civil case was brought
against the child
for something similar to the case that
they were the criminal case that was
against them
um i'm going to defer that question um
hopefully uh sarah blodgett from the uh
judicial council is going to
be testifying and she'll be able to
answer that question
great and then i just have one more mr
chairman sarah
sorry that's why we're here go ahead um
on part five with the
cheap the justices sitting in for the
circuit court
how would that affect um someone filed
an appeal
how would would that have
it seems like it would be a touchy
situation
um thank you for that question that was
uh something that we
did not discuss um but
um mr head who is head of the government
affairs
for the judicial branch hopefully we'll
be able to answer that question for you
great thank you so much senator carson
have a great day you too
thank you representative rice are there
other questions for senator cars
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you very much mr chairman have a
great day and i will
um forward not only the hearing report
but also the request
for i'll get an amendment and when i get
that i will make sure that you folks get
it
that would be greatly appreciated thank
you very much mr chairman
have a great day everyone
it's uh senator rosenwald
she's there
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee
for the record i'm cindy rosenwald
senator from district 13
in nashua and i did file
section 8 cyber security incident
reporting
this was a request of doit
and commissioner goulet i believe is
one of the attendees can answer
questions
i wanted to just mention that the senate
amended the language to
add a hold harmless provision
for subdivisions which were not
previously aware of the security
incident
and with that i will conclude thank you
mr
chairman
are there any questions for senator
roosevelt
sing none thank you thank you
uh senator prentice
if you
are there senator apprentice could you
raise your hand
uh this is um this is uh commissioner
dennis goulet i'm the individual who
raises
his hand um right but um
i was calling on you're not testifying
for senator prentice are you
um no uh for senator rosenwald on on
part eight
okay we're not going by parks oh i'm
sorry
you can mute me thank you
i don't see senator francis
senator gray
there he is he's there this is senator
gray
i'm uh the center for my district six
representing alton barnstead gilmanton
new durham rochester and farmington i am
the
the prime sponsor of part two of the
bill
there's two concepts i want you to
remember when you're looking at
part two and that is uh
failure failure to report collateral
assets
and the uh ability
for uh the state to recoup the funds
from future grants right now the
law as it is enacted only allows them to
recruit those assets from future grants
and that is especially important if the
uh person has failed to report
collateral assets
something they own um so
the state you know in taking care of our
blind our aged
our disabled and our dependent children
need to be a good steward of those funds
and right now the statute
hampers us in doing that in those two
areas
so um the department has asked me to
submit this bill
i'm sure that the very talented uh
franchesca hennessey
will be here to testify and give you
more detail on that
but those are the two concepts that i
want you to take away from this
is is recovering funds for people who
have
misstated or failed to report
assets that they have and
our ability to collect the money or
recoup the money in other ways other
than just with
lower future grants if you have any
questions of me i'd be
happy to try and answer them are there
any questions first senator gray
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you
and i don't see any other
senators or representatives who have
signed up to testify
so going down the list there's
david nicholadys
hey sir can you hear me weekend
hey hey thanks for having me uh to
members of the house judiciary committee
i'm major general david mikulitis uh the
adjutant general for the new hampshire
national guard
uh i'm here to talk on behalf of section
12 that senator carson was kind enough
to submit legislation for us um
we provide a tuition waiver at any state
university for any soldier airman who
joins the national
our guard hampshire scholarship fund is
somewhat antiquated in a sense that
um it's just not a significant benefit
it
that it used to be based upon the
tuition waiver that we get at any state
university
however the number one biggest strategic
challenge to an
all-volunteer force is the ability for
us to fill our formations
um there's no line at our door we're
constantly trying to recruit the next
greatest generation into our formations
and it has been a struggle since only 29
of today's youth is eligible for
military service
um whether it's childhood obesity
prescription medication
lack of a high school degree you name it
the challenges
of an all-volunteer force are
significant
what this uh proposed legislation will
do
is it will allow a current guardsman
who's enlisted like us
private a sergeant up to junior officers
and new hampshire national guard
retirees
to earn a 500 cash benefit
for recruiting additional soldiers and
airmen into our formations
i mean it's that simple um we struggle
to fill our formations every year we
need to recruit about 350 new soldiers
and airmen
and it has been a constant challenge the
new hampshire army national guard
is the smallest national guard per
capita to its population
in the country and we have a concerted
effort to both fill our formations and
grow our formations
and that's why the reason why we ask
senator carson to propose this
legislation for us
you know subject to your questions
that's all i have
yes representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um i'm so sorry i missed your rank
uh major general ma'am major general
thank you i wanted to
say that properly is is this my husband
was a recruiter for the national guard
for years and then the program
stopped probably maybe seven eight years
ago is this the same program as before
no that was a federal program that they
discontinued
okay it's similar in function
but it's different in the sense that um
you know this would be for state
general funds versus that it was a prior
program that was uh
you know for the federal government all
right thank you so much for clarifying
that for me
so as as i understand the program it's
as simple as you find somebody who
enlists
and if you do you're you're a current
member of the national guard
you get you get a 500 bonus basically
that's it that's it simple just uh we're
referral business
um that's how it usually works and so
you know if we can entice a
you know high school graduate who joins
the national guard
to say that he had a positive experience
and trying to get some of his friends to
join
that's how his total works
representative lorenzo thank you mr
chair
and thank you um general for taking my
question
and my question is around retention of
those recruits for whom the bonus is
um paid for is there like a requirement
as to how long the person has to be
in the guard before the bonus is paid
uh no ma'am so you usually will happen
is a tournament enlistment for a
new soldier airman joining the national
guard is typically six
years what we would do is we would
probably wait for them to complete their
basic training and then what's called
their advanced individual training
in order to make sure they've been
properly assessed
into the guard and they can begin their
service obligation
so instead of just giving to a kid when
he just uh raises his hand
you know we would set up a policies and
procedures to allow that bonus not to
occur until that
individual is physically in our
formations after the completion of their
basic training
oh thank you very much
are there other questions for the
general yes
representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you ms um
general micheladas for taking my
question
could you clarify for me i didn't
understand um in the beginning when you
were talking about the tuition
reimbursement
are you planning to continue that uh
within the university system or how is
that changing
uh ma'am uh no change to that i just
wanted to suggest to you that
you know the university system of new
hampshire and the community college
system of new hampshire have been
stellar supporters of the national guard
and that benefit or free tuition waiver
tony state university
is just more appealing than giving out a
small scholarship to someone
and that's why we want to take those
funds it was 25
000 and almost put this to an incentive
enlistment incentive program
thank you thank you are there
other questions for the general
thank you very much for your testimony
today
all right thanks sir thanks for having
me next will be uh
senator daniels
good morning mr chairman member of the
committee um
my apologies uh we had to miss
miscommunication so
i didn't get signed in initially but
i'm here today to introduce part 11. of
the insurance
company licenses at the request of the
department of
insurance this part will accomplish two
things
it updates the statute for insurance
company licensing applications to
include a
reference of complying with the national
association
of insurance commissioners uniform
standards
though applicants are required to meet
naic's
uniform standards to obtain a license
there is no mention of those standards
in our statutes this proposal will
remedy that condition
secondly it amends the department of
revenue administration statute
to allow them to share information with
about the business
enterprise tax credit so the bet
credits with the department of insurance
so the department can
verify the proper premium taxes being
collected
the insurance industry is supportive of
this proposal
and i believe that there are folks here
from the insurance department to answer
any questions that the committee may
have regarding
uh part 11. i thank you for your
consideration of this legislation
other questions for senator daniels yes
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman um senator daniels
when i was reading through
um title 11 i saw a term called
foreign and foreign insurance companies
does that mean
overseas foreign companies or
out-of-state companies
thank you um if i may uh
i don't i believe that marty mobley
from the department of insurance may be
on i can't see the participants
um i think they would probably be better
in answering that question than i
all right thank you thank you
we will try to get an answer to your
question
representative
i don't see marty mowgli as a
attendee although marty mo we did sign
in
in support of the bill
and
next we have heather silverstein
hello good morning can you hear me
hi uh my name is heather silverstein i'm
general counsel for the new hampshire
insurance
department uh yes marty's handling
another um
hearing today i'll be testifying on this
bill and
to the question posed about the foreign
um companies those are out of state
companies so that's how our that's how
that it's a little confusing if you're
not in the insurance industry but that's
just what that means out of state
companies that are not
the home state is not insurance and
domestic companies are
there their home state is here in new
hampshire so
um so part 11 i'll just briefly um
uh senator danner's did a great job of
going over
the scope of the part 11. basically
we're trying to clean up
the licensing statute for domestic and
foreign companies to make sure it's
clear
we use any ic standards national
association of insurance commissioners
to make sure companies have proper
capital um that they're safe reliable
it's done nationwide it's not a surprise
to industry
so making this change is really a good
thing
um as far as the licensing piece
is considered the other part of the bill
pertaining to revenue and wanting to
amend rsa21j14
roman numeral 5d um so what happens is
the our licensees like insurance
companies they can take
um they they paid a revenue a business
enterprise tax
so if they do that they can get a credit
from their premium taxes with our
department
and currently the way it's set up is we
can't get the information from revenue
because of the way the statute is
to find out what they actually paid to
revenue
so this exception that we're asking for
is just um a way to have revenue be able
to share that information with us
so that we can um char um so that we
know that we are charging the proper
premium tax that this
credit that was taken was the right
amount of the credit um how that works
is
it gets reported in 2000 as far as the
business enterprise tax gets reported
paid to revenue in 2020 and then a
company could say to our department
um we would like credit uh in 2021
and we would give them credit but we
have no way of going back to revenue to
find out if
what we're giving for credit is actually
accurate this would also
require a memorandum of understanding
we share information with revenue our
statute does not permit it
but theirs does and we this um
exception is very narrow i actually
drafted this it's tailored to the
employment security
uh exception that's on the statute under
i believe number six so it's very
similar
um we're just we want the information
just to make sure everything is accurate
and everything remains confidential
i am happy to take questions if you have
any
representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh can you tell me
what kind of
entity uh naic is
uh so the nasa national association of
insurance commissioners
all of the states are in this
association
and it's so that our it helps our
licensees because we
develop at you know nationwide we
develop
regulations and laws and then we
introduce them
into each of our states so that the
standards are more uniform
so you don't have companies having to uh
abide by all these different regulations
and all these different laws and
and the states and doesn't mean that we
don't have some variation because we do
but it's a way to collaborate and make
it easier on our licensees
uh so that there's similar standards
applied
if i can follow up you sure can um
so i don't think i exactly maybe asked
the
question incorrectly but uh legally is
this a non-profit
is it a government entity is it a
private corporation
yeah i believe it's a non-profit um and
it's it's it's all states are involved
uh
you know we pay a membership to be part
of the association
uh we go to seminars at the neic um
takes we collaborate with other states
when we're developing
model laws and model rules which we may
introduce
into the states and
there's a lot of discussion with
industry with consumer groups
during that process so it's a very um
collaborative effort and it helps us
pool our resources as well
and again it doesn't mean that just
because a model law
was developed at the neic that we're
gonna
introduce it just the way it was but
a lot of times we will take you know the
base of it at least
um if it's something that we think is
you know reliable makes sense for
industry makes sense for
consumers thank you thank you
any other questions
if not thank you for your testimony
today
thank you next person is sarah blodge
good morning mr chairman and committee
members i'm sarah blodgett with the new
hampshire judicial council
and i'm speaking to part one of this
bill
the appointment of counsel for minor in
a juvenile delinquency proceeding
as i believe most of you are aware
the judicial council received a an
assessment by the national
juvenile defender center the end of this
past summer
regarding their assessment of the
quality of representation that is
provided to
juveniles in delinquency proceedings
and is part of the response to that
the judicial council took a position on
house bill 188 that was spent sponsored
by
representative burch that
went to address many of the issues that
were raised in the njdc
assessment the judicial council did not
take a formal position
on this bill but the language regarding
juvenile representation
is almost identical to the language that
was in representative burge's bill
and the judicial council although there
was not a quorum present
did vote in favor of that bill
and this language addresses several of
the concerns that were raised by the
national juvenile defender center
one of the concerns was the need for
earlier appointment of counsel
and this bill allows for that to take
place
it also tightens up the scenarios in
which a juvenile is allowed to
waive their right to counsel one of the
issues i know representative
rice brought up was a concern that i
believe came up
with representative burch's bill that
some of the language here could be seen
as an extension of the right to counsel
for juveniles in
civil proceedings and i i think
that in in drafting this language the
intent
was to have an attorney
representing a juvenile in a delinquency
proceeding
work with that same juvenile to prevent
them from
speaking about the the charges the
allegations at issue
uh in the delinquency but i i
understand that concern and i believe
that the
remainder of this bill is so crucial to
addressing
the national juvenile defender center
recommendations
that i would be happy to work with
anybody on an amendment
that may address the concerns about a
significant expansion of the right to
counsel
i will also say that i think that um
recent changes recent charges rather
that came from the ydc investigation is
a reminder to all of us
about the vulnerability of children
involved in the juvenile justice system
and so i think it's important to address
the concerns about this bill
but also to have a lot of the changes
that this bill would
accomplish go through this session so
that we can really start to
work on addressing some of the areas
that need
improvement i'm happy to take questions
and i thank you all for your time
representative
uh thank you mr chair uh thank you uh
sarah blodgett for your uh coaching
testimony and i wanted to also speak
just briefly as to the issue raised
uh by representative rice uh
it's a fair issue to raise and it's a
fair issue
the the group that worked on original
bill 188
um wrestled with what language to use
uh to avoid the idea
that appointed council could represent
uh juveniles and all sorts of civil
matters we did not want to go in that
direction
the actual language in this bill
which i'm reading from
says has a lot of guard rails to it
says representation shall include
representation
at related proceedings as one guardrail
when such matters are based on the same
factual circumstances
second guard rail as the petition
and involvement in the related
proceeding is necessary
to provide effective representation on
the petition
third guard rail so we've put in three
there in this bill three guard rails
to limit um that
that concern and also the representation
ends
when uh the court no longer has
jurisdiction over the child
so that that becomes a fourth guard rail
in any event i'm happy to work with
representative rice
uh and talk this issue over and see if
we can come up with language or uh agree
that the language now with the four
guard rails is sufficient either way i'm
happy to
to work with representative rice
presuming that was a question
yes do you would not agree
are there any other questions
i one just
a question only because it comes from
our experience with
house bill 188 and it seemed that
there was a substantial criticism of
one particular part and that was with
regard to
juvenile statements or confessions and
how they might be
used is from your perspective
is that a critical part of the bill or
is representation of the juvenile
itself more important
thank you for the question mr chairman
that was one of the recommendations in
the national
juvenile sen national juvenile defender
center assessment
but it is that is a big step forward
um for representation and i
i will say that that is
if new hampshire were to implement that
piece of this bill
we would be one of the few jurisdictions
in the nation that had taken that step
i know that there are other
jurisdictions that
provide for council at interrogation
um but it would be a
a significant step forward for new
hampshire
and i think that in addition to
the change that that would would
implement
it would also be a significant financial
requirement for us to put into place a
system that would have the public
defender
available to respond at any time of the
day or night when a juvenile is being
questioned by
law enforcement and i certainly
understand the intent
of that requirement i think we have all
learned
quite a bit over the past few years
about adolescent brain development
and what adolescents are really able to
understand and process
and so certainly um and with my history
as a
former public defender i do see
the importance of this um
but i would say that some of the other
areas that this
bill covers really are fundamental needs
that we need to address in new hampshire
representative rice
thank you mr chairman i'm wondering if
it would be possible since we're talking
on part one
if we could hear from michelle wangren i
know
she was working um on hb 188
and i'd really like to hear what they
came up with before we
lose sight and end up in another part
i'd like to see if we could
kind of keep it on this part for a
minute would that be possible
if she's available i see her hand up so
i'm hoping
good afternoon good morning excellent
hi good morning committee my name is
michelle wong i'm an attorney at new
hampshire
legal assistance and the director of the
youth law project
representative rice thank you for for
recognizing
recognizing me and thank you mr chair so
i
i did work extensively on hb 188 and
have been
involved in some pretty extensive
discussions on sb
143 as well i will say that after
for those of you who are familiar with
what happened with
hb 188 it did pass through the committee
unanimously
but um former justice and representative
lynn had some pretty significant
concerns
about a number of portions of that bill
uh attorney skibby and i did have the
opportunity to
meet with justice lynn to talk about um
some of his concerns and try to work
through them
you know i think you know in terms of um
the bill there are a number of areas
where i think that
everyone recognizes their um they are
good practice
under the the new hampshire juvenile
defender center report
we know that new hampshire needs to have
earlier appointment of counsel
we know that children are entering court
for the first time
having never consulted with counsel let
alone having counsel available to them
uh we know that there is a problem with
how we structure
payment of contract attorney fees and
there's a significant disincentive
to for them to provide effective and
extensive juvenile representation
we know that
we know that we need a better
performance standards
for for juvenile defenders uh which has
been highlighted
as a recommendation from the national
juvenile defender center
i think the areas of disagreement that
we had with representative lynn i think
some of them
are resolvable and and one of them is
not
um the primary areas of disagreement
were
um in terms of the ancillary proceeding
language
and participation in proceedings
that outside of the delinquency process
i think his concern was that that
that the language that was inserted in
hb 188
may presume that juvenile defenders
could
formally represent kids at say
small claims actions that is not the
purpose of this bill
you know my thought process behind the
ancillary proceedings language
is to ensure solely that juveniles are
entitled to
effective and competent counsel i think
there's um
there's some disagreement on the extent
to juvenile representation in
proceedings outside of the delinquency
process
and as a former public defender and a
current practitioner of
juvenile law in in civil proceedings i
can say that there is this
this small area of significant overlap
we have a juvenile delinquency statute
that
says that in order for a petition to be
sufficient
a school district has to ensure that it
has tried certain approaches and that
it has determined whether or not a
behavior is
is um has a relationship
to a child's disability
if we say that a juvenile defender
can can file a motion
that a petition is insufficient but at
the same time
we bar them from attending a school
proceeding
directly related to whether or not the
petition is sufficient
that is not effective in competent
counsel and so
in working through this with with
justice lynn
i thought a lot about some language to
perhaps tighten
um this that section of the bill
and and and address some of those
concerns and i'd be happy to
work with um both both representative
lin and any
any members of the committee that would
might be interested in working through
some of that language
um another section that has been
highlighted is this appointment at
interrogation
and and again i think that's
the i think the main concern that has
come up is that the language and the
bill
may be too broad and may extend
appointment of counsel prior to
a petition being filed to any form of
questioning
as opposed to custodial interrogation
and so i think that again that is an
area that
um you know i have certainly some ideas
on how to
work through that language to make it
clear that
we mean custodial interrogation but in a
juvenile centered way
recognizing that there are pressures
placed on juveniles during police
questioning
in a way that may not be present for
adults who are questioned
um the third area that i think that it
was some disagreement
is um repayment of counsel
fees and i know that that's an area
that the national juvenile defender
center really
strongly recommended that we eliminate
reimbursement of
council fees for juveniles the rationale
behind that
is because there are some some pressures
that are inherently on juveniles
when their parents are paying their
bills so if a juvenile
um wants to contest a
a delinquency petition um
there may be some pressure by parents to
say look just take responsibility
for this plea true don't cost me
money and and by eliminating those fees
it inherently removes that pressure on
juveniles and i will say that in terms
of my experience
sometimes those pressures are really
extensive the burdens that juveniles
feel
whether or not they're expressed by
parents
or not can be incredibly significant
i've worked with kids who are worried
about putting their family
deeper into poverty by having these
council fees i've worked with kids who
have
contemplated suicide because they might
get their families deported
through their behavior i i've worked
with kids who
feel these pressures of the juvenile
system
in ways that are very difficult to
understand when you're not in it
and eliminating um council fees for
juveniles in particular
and and eliminating that burden for them
is both good practice as highlighted by
the
the njdc report and also
is um it's not expensive the cost of
collecting these fees
is almost as much as the
amount of fees the state collects and i
don't have the exact numbers on that
but it's nearly a wash so eliminating
those fees would
would not be um would not be a heavy
lift i will say that that was an area
of disagreement with with justice lynn
that we were not able to overcome but we
could certainly con
um continue that conversation and i
would love to do that
in this legislative session to see if we
can find those points of agreement
with members of this committee and
hopefully move this
forward so that we at least have some
portion of the bill
that goes into effect in the in the
coming months
and i'm happy to take any questions that
the committee may have
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
attorney wandering for your
uh thoughtful and detailed testimony
uh in the issue of uh use of statement
or confession of a minor
is it not true that the way the statute
is drafted
it doesn't require that council be
present
before any interrogation it's just
that if there is
a wish to use the product
of interrogation against the juvenile
in a court proceeding then the juvenile
would have to have had counsel afforded
uh to him or her am i reading that
correctly
yes uh representative barton thank you
for that question that's exactly right
so in an emergent circumstance it would
provide no barrier to law enforcement
questioning a juvenile
to um learn information
that is urgent um and
if the juvenile does not have counsel
present during that questioning you know
i think that if we if we tweak with the
lang the
language and you know and make it
custodial interrogation i think some
factors would have to be looked at but
as the bill is written
now and as you know i would propose it
be amended
that's exactly right there would be no
barrier on questioning there would only
be a barrier to usage
unless it's a council statement
and if i could follow up um
uh you you referenced i think it was you
that referenced that this might
it might have been sarah blodgett about
the cost involved
um i'm wondering if you looked at all to
our neighboring state of vermont
where i practiced where every juvenile
who was interrogated had an opportunity
to talk to counsel at virtually no cost
to the state simply by having an on-call
public defender statewide system where
um i know i had to at one night uh
every three months uh be available to
take those phone calls
and and tell the the juvenile not answer
any questions
so i'm wondering if you had looked at
other systems which were actually very
low or no cost
uh and yet give a bright line which the
law likes
uh a bright line for juveniles as to uh
the ability to consult with counsel
so i i haven't but i will say this
um i i will say that practically
speaking
having earlier appointment of counsel is
more likely to
make the system less expensive and i say
that under current practice and i also
say that because there's another bill
sb 94 that may be coming to your
committee i'm not sure if it's going to
child and family law or this committee
okay that will um that will
allow for diversion of more children
from the juvenile system entirely
and i think the benefit of
before counsel petition is ever filed
and at
the interrogation stage is there's many
times that juveniles make mistakes
that are technically violations of the
law that do not require them
to enter the juvenile system at all um
and having that earlier appointment of
counsel can both
help the juvenile understand the various
off-ramps and buy into those various
off-ramps
much earlier in the system than sailing
them down the river through juvenile
court which is a
very intimidating and scary process for
many of them
and and the other thing i'll say is that
and maybe this is this is dating myself
and
but you know when i was a kid um
and kids went and spoke with law
enforcement
there were many um
options for them you know working with
law enforcement in general and having
an attorney facilitate a conversation
with law enforcement
can help um can help the child and law
enforcement develop creative solutions
for diverting a child is it let's you
know do some community service
is it um you know i'm going to connect
you with
these various resources you know the law
enforcement
law enforcement will connect the child
with various resources
and find a creative solution and i think
there's a lot of value
in having an attorney facilitate that
conversation
to help divert the children from the
system entirely
and certainly in the wake of sb 94
and you know a greater greater adherence
to
needs assessments and figuring out what
is effective
for any particular juvenile i think an
attorney could
provide a lot of value in facilitating
that and counseling the child
to take advantage of some of the options
available to them
rather than being an adversary body in
the process
i'm sorry mr chairman did you call me
yes
okay thank you thank you um thank you
michelle for
your testimony and um i just have
one more question and i i don't want
people to think i'm opposed to this i i
like this concept i think this is really
important i just want us to do it right
um i am concerned one of the other
concerns that representative lynn had
brought
to our attention was confessions to a
cousin
or a friend he was concerned that they
would then in turn not be
allowed to testify um
in court also if a police officer had
pulled a child
a kid over who was driving that the
police officer wouldn't be
able to say what's in that white baggy
or what's
what's that white powder in that baggie
something to that effect
did we come to um
some sort of a mutual
agreement so that that this doesn't
happen
so thank you for the question i think
that's important so that's exactly the
issue i was getting
uh in terms of um
perhaps developing an amendment that
would
limit the exclusion of juvenile
confessions to custodial interrogation
and and so i think i think we can
absolutely get there um you know the the
question of what's in that white baggie
i think that's a little bit more
complicated
because if it's you know a law
enforcement that is asking that question
for the purpose of eliciting a
confession to use in court
um you know i i think that that
particular question
would need to be weighed but what but
again
what i want to go back to is that if
there
is um you know if there's a question of
where's the body
where you know law enforcement needs to
know right now where something is
there is not a limitation on asking the
juvenile that
eliciting an answer the only limitation
would be on use of court
now does law enforcement need to know
right in that moment
you know what's in the baggie i think
that is that type of question is more
um designed to elicit a
an incriminatory response as opposed to
something that is urgent um to prevent
harm to a person so you know i i think
there may continue to be some
disagreement
on whether or not that's a fair question
to ask
and then use in court but i do think
with a limitation on custodial
interrogation
we get to a much more comfortable place
great i agree thank you thank you any
other questions
yes representative lorenzo
representative lorenzo you're muted
you have to learn
there we go thank you thank you mr
chairman and thank you michelle and
my question is around um
[Music]
the term juvenile delinquent and this is
very broad but it is
an impression that i had when i was
reading over
this spill and i think that the term
juvenile delinquent
is stigmatizing and it's archaic
in view of the social science that we
now have considering
why kids go just just go astray
and i think that the term could be
impede the rehabilitation of of the
child
um we know that um especially in the
community
you know a child that's
a juvenile offender who's been like
called a juvenile delinquent that impact
impacts the kids standing in the
community
in this school in their neighborhood um
and it places a stamp on them
and the reasons why some kids go astray
is
because of disability or mental health
issues
um and that term will stick with the
child for the rest of their
their life i think that we know through
social science research that there are
multiple reasons
why kids get into the juvenile justice
system
and sometimes it's not the child's fault
sometimes it has to do with a family
environment
and those environmental issues could
include mental health issues in the
family
court involvement of the family and then
substance misuse
issues in the family but um
the term juvenile delinquent was kind of
a turn off for me and i just wanted to
raise that concern
thank you thank you representative de
lorenzo i will point out that the term
troop now delinquent actually has a very
specific definition
it means that a child has committed an
offense that
would be a misdemeanor or felony if
committed by the
by an adult and that the child is in
need of services i don't disagree with
you
on you know the stigmatizing effect and
i encourage
this committee to take a very strong
look at sb 94 when it comes over
because the purpose of that bill is to
limit juveniles from entering the
juvenile system and acquiring that label
and i think it it's the result of a lot
of really exciting work that is another
another talk for another day
representative oregon
you act on mute
um i know this would the term juvenile
delinquent appears in lots of places in
the law and then we've got the whole
you know political climate everybody's
upset about wokeness and cancer culture
and stuff and you know
we have a rather strange thing that's in
the house budget though i don't know if
that's going to pass but
uh what specific question is would it be
worthwhile either through
this bill or sb941 to perhaps
redefine and maybe even rename juvenile
delinquency so it's
just uh i know obviously anytime you do
that there's going to be a certain
amount of what they call
dysphemism creep where like you create a
new euphemism for something and then it
becomes a pessimism a bad word but would
it be worthwhile to
perhaps rename and redefine the concept
of juvenile delinquency at this time
thank you for the question i don't i i
don't know that i have an answer on that
um i think that's a beyond the scope of
of what i've thought about this bill but
i think it's an interesting question
all right thank you representative rice
thank you mr chairman um you know to be
quite honest i think anything that we
changed the name from
in three years is going to offend
someone i think we need to stick to the
importance of this bill
and work on getting this passed rather
than working on changing a name that in
three years
somebody's going to be offended by and
find demeaning
and then we have to change it again i
would really just like to see us
work on this bill and get it right so
that these kids have counsel
right away and not worry about the word
delinquent which
in juvenile offender could offend
someone or put a stigma on them
you know but i think we're getting way
off base as to
the intent of this bill okay
i'm sorry again anybody can submit an
amendment if they
want but we'll keep our focus where
it needs to be so okay
any other questions for attorney landry
singh thank you for your testimony today
thank you
i do want to uh call first on those
people who
signed up in advance because it seems to
me that
they should be recognized first before i
go down
the list of other people so uh michael
skibby
his hand was
thank you mr chairman um michael skibby
um i'm the policy director at the
disability rights center
um testifying in support of part one
of senate bill 143 my testimony will be
very brief because i think that
um your conversation with michelle
wongan has really covered
much of the territory in a in i think a
pretty comprehensive way um michelle and
i
are members of a group known as the
juvenile reform project which
includes my office her office the aclu
of new hampshire
waypoint and new futures we've been
working for a number of years on
a variety of juvenile delinquency reform
efforts i i think that
i will just briefly touch on a couple of
things that
that may not have been discussed in
earlier in the hearing
the immediate appointment of counsel is
a very important
provision that is in
just want to make sure that i'm giving
you the right section numbers um
that would be in section one there there
it is right at the beginning um
basically the point here is that many
things happen at the first appearance in
court
and current new hampshire practice does
not
really provide for the immediate
appointment of counsel unless a child is
actually in custody
um and is going to be held in custody
for some extended period of time
and a lot happens at that first
appearance and it's important
for families and children to have
assistance
at that first appearance it actually can
end up being a time saver and a resource
saver for everyone involved because
sometimes cases that are minor in nature
can be resolved quickly
reducing the need for a return
appearance of a police officer a
prosecutor
family taking time off from work
children taking time off from school etc
the the provision that provides for
um for um
council to be appointed um and that
waiver is not permitted unless
that this is section three that that
basically
a child can't waive their right to
counsel unless they have a
an opportunity to consult with a lawyer
about the consequences of that waiver
that's the national standard we've been
slowly incrementally moving towards
adoption of that standard for certain
categories of kids
um most prominently kids with just with
sort of recognized disabilities
um and this would basically say look
let's just go the whole way
we're gonna appoint council immediately
in these cases if the if at some point
the child wants to waive counsel that
has to happen
after they've had a chance to talk to a
lawyer about the consequences of it
the last thing i'll mention is the flat
fee provision
which is the section is section
five on page three of the bill um
as i'm sure you know um the the
compensation for lawyers for poor people
is pretty low and that in and of itself
regardless of how it's structured
creates a disincentive to work on these
cases
if you have other higher paying cases
you know in the office
and so we in new hampshire we compound
that
by basically saying you're going to get
the same amount of money if you work one
hour on a case or if you work 10 hours
on a case
and so we really have a doubly
you know poorly structured system
and it's particularly dangerous i think
when you're talking about
cases involving children with which can
um involve
a fair amount of complexity because
children with disabilities are much more
likely to be court involved
they can be involved in multiple service
systems that they can be complex
that in in the complexity is not often
really directly tied to the seriousness
of the actual charge so
i think that's a very important
provision as well um i will leave it at
that
you've got a lot to talk about and i'd
be happy to answer any questions
any questions for return skippy
yes representative rice
you're mute
there we go thank you sorry about that
um
mr skibby real quick question on when we
had hb 188 did we not amend that to
hourly for the attorney fees
yes there was a very similar but
slightly different provision
in uh the 188 language it actually
provided for an hourly rate
this this basically um
gives a little bit more flexibility as
to how it could be structured you could
have sort of a phased
compensation under this language whereas
188 required an
hourly rate um i think we can live with
either
follow-up i'm sure mr chairman just
really quickly okay so that's
that's my concern what's going to give
the kids the best representation
what's going to make sure that
they're not being pushed aside for the
higher paying cases
which which part do you think will work
better i think that um
probably the most reliable way to do it
to ensure that lawyers don't have the
disincentive
of not getting paid for each additional
effort that they put into it is to go
with the hourly rates um i
you know there are ways of structuring
these kinds of contracts that
are not truly flat fees but where you
say okay if the case is resolved at this
stage it's one fee
if it's resolved at some later
procedural point in the case it's
another fee
um those um are still imperfect
because it still creates the
disincentive to work
to work more on each stage of the case
it's somewhat better than the actual
flat fee but i think the hourly
rate is probably the best way to go okay
great thank you so much
any other questions for attorneys
thank you for your testimony thank you
and
kevin grady
hi good morning can you hear me mr
chairman we can hear you fine
great for the record my name is kevin
grady
and i am a 22-year resident of hooksett
following a 25-year career in our air
force
today i'm here representing the 20
members of the state veterans advisory
committee
to talk specifically to section 12
of the bill about the national guard
enlistment uh recruiting
plan uh general micheladas did a fine
job so i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on that i'm just
going to tell you all that we we do
support this bill
and the the the fund that used to exist
that they're
they're creating this new fund and
getting rid of the old one
that fund was primarily used for things
like
if a if a recruit wanted to get a cdl
license or something there that wasn't
really covered by the university system
and they found that there really wasn't
a lot of of uh
of call for that and so that's why
they're they're they're going this other
direction
but the only thing i wanted to tell you
is that our members do support this
and subject to your questions that's all
i wanted to tell you
thank you for your succinct testimony
and are there any questions for mr grady
thank you and thank you for your
patience thank you sir
and the last person who signed up in
advance
is uh richard head turning ahead
um good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee
my name is richard head i'm the
government affairs coordinator for the
judicial
branch um and before i begin you should
also have
margaret huang who signed up to testify
and for some reason doesn't sound like
it made it to your list she was going to
speak to part three
of senate bill 143 i was going to speak
to in support of sections 4 5
6 and 7. and mr chairman i'll
take it as as is your preference if you
would prefer that i pause between each
part
and answer questions or if you would
prefer me to go through all the sections
and then answer questions at the end
uh whichever is your preference why
don't you go through each part
and stop and ask if there are any
questions
perfect so i'll begin with part four
which is on page six of the bill this
would allow
the administrative judge of the circuit
court or the supreme court uh
chief justice to appoint or actually
there's the administrator
administrative judge to appoint referees
to any
uncontested matter of certain types in
probate
uh and those are specifically probate of
wills and granting the administration on
on all matters
and name changes this would uh
essentially allow some more efficiency
within the
within the probate court to allow the
referees to be able to issue orders
they're working under the supervision of
a probate judge
and if there is a request for
reconsideration
that request for reconsideration would
be reviewed by
a judge not the referee uh and just
uh to go back and remind the committee a
referee
is a a judge who has retired at age 70
and is no longer qualified to sit as a
judge but can sit as a referee
and this would simply allow them to
issue orders in any uncontested matter
where there was no objection
of any of the parties part four also
would repeal
a provision that puts the exclusive
jurisdiction
of termination of parental rights in
probate
because it is it should be in fact
expanded beyond that
to where it's primarily in the family
division now
and with that i will pause and be happy
to answer any questions
with regard to part four
representative mclean yeah uh thank you
mr chair and thank you for taking your
questions it's just a quick question
so um just sausage making
so if it's not contested i do see on
impart forces
um any party agreed by the decision
so i'm just kind of wondering how that
would come about to be if you have a
will
that's uncontested that you would have
someone that was aggrieved by the
decision
so how do you make the determination
that it's uncontested and how might such
a situation arise
you know i think it's probably rare or
unlikely but
even in an uncontested matter the judge
may include something in an order
that a party simply disagrees with or
was unexpected at the beginning
and may put something in the in the
order that was not
perhaps originally contemplated at the
time uh
that the matter was was initially being
considered i think
i think it's unlikely and rare but it's
it you always have to have
an off-ramp for for any party once they
actually receive an order
to uh to be able to take some some
additional step
uh and that just seems to be a good
safety valve just on the off chance that
something
unexpected shows up in the order that
was otherwise uncontested
thank you representative oregon um yes
i'd like
i'd like to delve a little bit more into
section two of part four about taking
termination of parental rights cases out
of the probate court i
unders i see there i certainly um i'm
certainly not surprised to hear that
they're mostly done in the family
division
but uh what's what's the problem with
also allowing the probate court to deal
with it and also currently what sort of
probate courses um cases do have
determination of parental rights as an
issue in them and how would
and is there any disadvantage to letting
the probate court continue to deal
whatever those situations are
going forward rather than bringing the
family division
into the uh into the proceeding
it actually doesn't prohibit the current
language makes them the exclusive
jurisdiction so it just
it broadens it now that we have a
circuit court
with three divisions it just it it takes
out the exclusive jurisdiction
language but doesn't create a
prohibition okay so
yes so you're saying follow-up um
it's basically it's unnecessary because
they're just two divisions of the same
court at the moment anyways in fact
that's right it might be the same judge
might just
put on his or her like take off his or
her family division hat
put on her probate half and then
somebody i guess might even be the same
judge in many cases
like big big part of it it could be so
it really is just a clean up
to to eliminate that exclusive
jurisdiction language okay
all right thank you representative
langley
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
now that i understand what a referee is
i'm not clear why that person would need
supervision by another judge
um as they've been a judge for a
significant period of time and
i would expect they have bring a certain
level of expertise
they thank you for the question they
absolutely do bring a level of expertise
um but currently uh
by a constitution they are no longer
allowed to sit as a judge
uh after age seventy so they are it's a
mandatory retirement at age 70.
so this so because because they are not
able to
continue to be as a judge after age 70
they have to be under the supervision of
a judge
but you're absolutely right the the
point here is
you have a number of very experienced uh
judicial officers who
can absolutely write these orders but
currently they all have to be
uh signed off by a judge and it really
is a an unnecessary step
for the most part in in these types of
cases where
where they're uncontested it just
consumes additional judicial resources
unnecessarily but it does as we
mentioned before at least provide a
a safety valve on the off chance that
there's some disagreement about what is
contained in that referee's order
that it could then be reviewed by um by
a current judge
thank you other questions
on section four representative birch
uh thank you mr chair and and thank you
attorney head for taking my question
your last answer raised a question for
me and that is
is this an end run in some respect
around the mandatory retirement age
for judges no it's an it's a
i i would not phrase it that way
currently the statutes
allow for referees um once you are
beyond your age 70 mandatory retirement
age
what this does is simply provides
the the orders can be issued by the
referee
with further review if necessary it just
avoids every order
from a referee needing to be reviewed
and
signed off for by a on the document
itself
on every order it it just is a
judicial efficiency question but does
not
allow the the referee to be acting as a
judge because they're always under the
supervision
of a judge and there's always the
opportunity for a judge
to then review it upon the request of
any party
and an issue a separate order
thank you representative rice thank you
mr chairman thank you mr head for taking
my question
um so this is for uncontested cases
correct
that's correct so follow up um
so just
i guess out of my own curiosity any
party agreed
by a decision why would there be a party
aggrieved by a decision if it's
uncontested
yeah and i think that's that's a similar
question as as we had before
really very very unlikely and and the
goal here is just to make sure
it's probably overly uh
careful but just on the chance that
notwithstanding the fact it is
uncontested
one of the when the when the actual
order is being reviewed and read by the
parties they see something that was
surprising to them
that was not expected when they were
when they were
essentially bringing the matter it gives
them a chance to have a judge look at it
and say
hey that was not what we had expected so
can you please look at this
very unlikely scenario but at least it
gives that
option one more follow-up if i may mr
chairman
um so what um
what how do i want to phrase this
ah what's the word i want to use um so
so these are retired judges what let's
say continuing education and competency
going forward do they have to
like i don't i don't know how do we make
sure that they're still okay
at 73. how do we do you know what i mean
does that
make any sense to you it does and and i
just need to pull up the
within the the provision that uh
provides
for uh referees essentially they would
they would continue on as referees
they're required to
um truth i don't
i need to pull up the language that's uh
that's
in the referee section so this bill this
would not
address the referee sort of requirements
um i just need to find it and i
apologize i didn't have that pulled out
it was just more out of curiosity i
understand that this section won't
affect that but we do want to still make
sure that
like at 73 are they still okay to make
these
these unilateral decisions so to speak
you know what i mean i'm not trying to
be mean but we
yeah well no i get that and that's why
no i and and certainly that type of
issue
came up with the bills that were both in
the senate in the house regarding the
retirement age
um of judges and whether or not that
should be
uh stricken in that in in at all times
uh as is currently true they would be
acting under the supervision of a judge
so if there is any problem in terms of
uh of of the capacity of a referee
that issue just has to be addressed
through the administrative judge
as to whether or not they are allowed to
and should be allowed to continue
sitting as a referee
um so they that that review is is a part
of sort of the
the duties of the the judge that is
actually
working with the referee i mean that
particular court wherever that court is
the um that judge who's who's
in charge of that court would would be
the one to make that evaluation
great thank you very much uh just for
clarification purposes
uh attorney attorney head not all
referees
are retired judges oh yeah fair point
thank you
and uh some some referees are
are senior judges who have retired
before age 70
and are allowed to continue in in
essentially a per diem
capacity um so so at some level there
are some judges who
uh who are not post 70.
and i thought actually in correct me i'm
wrong mr chairman i thought they were
actually referred to as senior judges
and not as referees but maybe i'm wrong
about that
people who are acting as referees who
have never been judged
is that true in the probate language
in the probate section of the statute i
don't i thought
i thought the referee was was a post-70
judge i have to say that i
appear and you would have more
experience than that so i i'll defer to
you
within the last year appeared in front
of a referee in the probate division
okay my fault then my error um
uh represent mclean it's a just a quick
question
as to need so i'm assuming the intention
of this is to be able to
to divert the the uncontested things
kind of get a fast track going
so if i look at what is the current
state
of processing these probate cases
and has any analysis been done as to how
this might
impact that current process would be the
referee
makes a recommendation that is then
reviewed
and approved uh and ordered by
a sitting judge um the
and and the process would be to divert
those that are uncontested with a
referee to allow the referee
to issue the order without that
requirement that every one of them is
reviewed
and ultimately issued by
by a setting judge i don't have numbers
uh it is you know there are a decent
number of them they do take up
uh judicial time but i honestly i did
not
i don't have a statistics today
although i'd be happy to get some as to
how many referee orders are signed off
by
uh by judges and ultimately issued by
judges
well i'm afraid i answered my question
ask my question
poorly i'm just wondering as to the need
is is there is there a significant
backlog that this is being brought in to
address
um and just trying to get a feel for
that i know
you know it is it's an efficiency so um
it's essentially able to free up the
sitting judge to work
on other orders instead of
going through the review of a referee's
order
and ultimately signing up
signing it as an order from that judge
um
it it so it's not you know it's not
specifically addressing a particular
backlog
um per se it is you know there's always
a very high demand
of judicial time so it's a way of just
trying to free up a little bit
of time for sitting judges
thank you representative simpson
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
attorney head for taking my question
i'm wondering um to the question
previous
question from the last one is it often
that people raise concerns about the
abilities of
retirees or senior judges or maybe more
more accurate what i want to ask is how
often do people raise concerns about
retirees or senior judges
extremely rarely
thank you
i could just inquire the issue really
here
is an economic decision because
currently you're required to have a
judge
which you pay a judge's 164
000 a year plus retirement benefits
and other benefits where
you can hire referees for
substantially less and not have to
pay them retirement benefits is that
correct
certainly that is that is a part of it i
think really the primary
motivating element was was the
efficiency
of the sitting judges in the time
they're currently taking but certainly
that would be a factor
because otherwise you could solve the
problem by having more judges
we can always we that's true that's fair
correct
unless there are other questions i think
we move on to part five
excellent part five is
um largely clarifying or fixing a little
issue in the current setup currently a
supreme court justice
can sit in the superior court but the
statute does not provide
a mechanism to go directly from the
supreme court as a justice to sit
temporarily
on some circuit court matters this
simply
expands the opportunity for a supreme
court justice
to be able to sit in either superior
court or circuit court
as a particular need may arise in
addressing representative rice's earlier
question
quite a little while ago the
um the issue of of what would happen if
if a
case were appealed to the supreme court
from the circuit court that that a
supreme court justice would
sit had set on obviously that justice
would be recused
from that appeal um it would not sit on
the appeal of
of their own order within the statute
and this is
in the current language relative to the
superior court
um it has to be that that the
designation is either by the chief
justice
or the senior associate um justice of
the supreme court
has to be in a manner that is not
inconsistent this is the language out of
the statute currently
not inconsistent with the proper
advancement of the business of the
supreme court
so the the you know whether or not it's
going to have an ultimate impact on the
supreme court's operation is a
is a consideration um and
for them you know for the most part
there
um the issue would be addressed if there
were an appeal
by a recusal by that justice when it's
heard by the supreme court
and with that i'll pause and and be
happy to answer any
questions regarding part five of the
bill
any questions on part five
seeing none um
thank you so turning to part six
part six is um
with regard to payment of costs for
services other than counsel for indigent
parties
this also is a clarification of existing
law
currently indigent council fees
are paid through the judicial council
which is not a part of the judicial
branch but is a separate agency
that is general funded and pays for the
the costs uh of certain fees
as is ordered by the the court so
um one thing i know in section six of
the bill
as it is coming off of at least the
website
it doesn't actually show the changes uh
when you read the bill it's all
uh neutral it doesn't have a bold it
doesn't have an underline
so it's a little bit awkward it's it's
not entirely new
uh each of these sections has an
additional sec
part to it and and truthfully i don't
know what happened the same thing was
true over in the senate
um but the first part deals with
it and as an aside the reason why this
is important
is because if there's ambiguity in the
statute or there's any
uh uncertainty in the statute the
judicial branch
would have to pay for it unless there's
some express
requirement for the payment to be
through the
judicial council and really the intent
of this uh
what's always been here is that these
fees are paid by the judicial council
so for example in the in the first
section um
we're talking about the costs of a
guardian ad litem and a termination of
parental right case
the statute is very clear currently that
the costs of the gal
are are covered but the gal may
themselves
have costs associated with their work
including the hiring of experts or
investigative fees or some other
service that may be necessary for
for their work in all of those things as
a as a collective package would
should be paid through the judicial
council
not by the judicial branch same thing
with the next section dealing with
costs of legal counsel those legal
counsel hire investigators higher
experts and have other services
that are necessary to provide adequate
representation
and again we're just making explicit in
the in the
statute through this bill that those
additional costs those investigative
costs experts and other services
would be uh would be included in what is
paid for
through the judicial council
again same thing with regard to the
other
two sections guardians and conservators
and criminal defense
we're talking about sort of making sure
all relative and related costs
are are packaged together and would be
processed through the judicial council
and with that i'll pause and be happy to
take any questions regarding part six
the first question is is the judicial
council in agreement with this
yes yes
representative rice hi thank you again
for taking my question i just had a
quick question on
on um
line eight of page eight my print out i
don't know if it's the same as yours
where it says adequate representation
for indigent defendants in criminal
cases
neglected or abused children can you
clarify that for me a little bit because
defendants in criminal cases would
i'm a little confused so i just need a
little clarification
yep these are um abuse and neglect cases
where
the there's a defendant that has been
charged with abuse of do
or neglect of a minor um and those
defendants are what we're talking about
who are who are entitled
to um to counsel
or actually i'm actually i let me make
sure
i didn't misspeak sorry uh this may be a
guardian i'd light him for
i'm sorry my fault i spoke too quickly
this is
in cases involving neglected abused
children when a guardian ad litem is
appointed for the child
such appointment is from funds from the
indigent defense
uh fund um
and then where the parent is where an
attorney is appointed to represent a
parent determined to be indigent
at the preliminary hearing or hearing
pursuant to the cost of the appointment
in there there we're adding the cost of
council
the investigative costs and related
expenses
and then the council would would be
petitioning the the
um the court okay
great thank you so much yes
representative chase
oh thank you thank you for taking my
question
mr herd on i'm just curious about
where the funds are coming from and if
it's in here and i don't know i'm not a
financial person
um yeah where where does is this
something that is
in the budget or is this something that
comes from
fees uh charge saved by
paying fines sure so thank you for the
question this is
uh the um judicial council
is almost entirely general funded so
it's budget
money um they may have and sheriff she's
still on could answer
um sarah blodgett might be honest or
more specifically they they may have
some other
um grant money but for the most part i
think it's general funded through the
through the biennial budget and up
yeah thank you and is
i i don't know if there is a note on
here but how much money is actually used
um do you have any idea wait i'm sorry
i don't have sort of the annual cost of
of these um i could certainly work with
sarah
to see what it is but i don't know today
i apologize that's okay i was just
curious how much is being used thank you
okay representative horrigan
mr chair thank you mr attorney head uh
my question is about um
tell us about paying the cost of a casa
guardian that lie appointment child or
other guardian enlightenment so
the there's another guardian little item
they're typically an attorney or some
other professional so they pay you know
they charge a rate that's uh you know
commensurate with the
market value of their services but then
but with the casa
i think the actual guardian that like
them
is a volunteer so what are what are the
costs i mean they're
i guess you're helping to pay the costs
the overhead of administering the casa
program
what are the costs related with a
volunteer asset guardian that lie down
truthfully i think that's probably a
better question
for sarah blodgett i don't
know exactly how they bill their their
serve their their legal services
um mr chairman i don't know if you know
but sarah blaged if she salon would be
the
person who could answer that question
i don't know that she is immediately
available
and i i'm certainly happy to uh
circle back with her and and provide the
committee with an answer
okay thanks
okay any other questions with regard to
section six
moving on to section seven great um last
section i was going to be talking on a
section seven
requiring uh allowing for penalty
assessment on violations
this again is a clarification um
with regard to um
uh penalty assessments when there was a
modification
of penalty assess or a penalty from a
misdemeanor to a penalty
um there became sort of a certain
level of uncertainty we wanted to just
make sure did not exist
so this is a clarification of of how we
currently interpret
the the law which is that penalty
assessment can be
assessed in a violation um and
you know this this just became sort of a
question in our
our minds that uh when when
certain misdemeanors were modified by
statute
in or by bill into a into a violation
um the um
so this this section just clarifies that
in fact they can be assessed
on a violation level offense and with
that i'd be happy to answer any
questions
representative thank you mr chair thank
you attorney head
just to clarify this section
does this section in and of itself
increase the amount of uh
fee or a penalty in any respect
it does not no it just it simply adds
the violation
but does not change the fee or the the
calculation
thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you mr chairman just
also reiterate margaret huang
did register to testify regarding part
three so i'm not talking to that section
well i don't have her registered to
testify that she may be
available to testify i don't know she
didn't pre-register
oh i see she is there i note that
uh you're the last representative uh
attorney had you the last of the people
who pre-registered the testified
so there's there's actually a funky
little thing in the registration process
which i
which i believe i now have figured out
is if you register
as a judicial branch employee it never
makes it to you if you register
as a state agency employee which is how
i registered it does make it to you
and i'm not quite sure what happened and
there's a glitch in the registration
system
that i i think i've just identified um
which i'll talk to the to the clerks
about okay
and we have some people who have been
waiting this uh
francesca hennessey
good morning this is francesca hennessey
from the department of health and human
services
i'm testifying in support
um the department is in support and
actually asked for part two
um the main objective of this
legislation i i will be brief unless
there's questions
is to allow the department to collect
overpayments from
a recipient not just by way of
recruitment which the
statute currently um allows for
but recipient allows the recipient
to affirmatively pay back to the state
um
and in fact recipients already do this
they already want to pay back
affirmatively
um and they asked to do this so it's
more of a cleanup of this section
and senator gray correctly pointed out
too
that we are also trying to clean up a
few other parts of this bill
i'm sorry of the statute by allowing
um failure to report collateral
resources to also be a reason to pay
back the department
um we this would also
um allow us to hold another individual
jointly and severally liable if they
assisted
in defrauding the state
we did consult and come to an agreement
with new hampshire legal assistance
on this language
so that too i hope is agreeable to
everyone
if they're that's all i have to say on
our bill again it's really cleaning up
the statute
are there any questions
so just so i understand this is with
regard to
recruitment and this is where you may
have
overpaid or you have paid benefits and
they have an obligation to reimburse the
state for those benefits
that's true that's true representative
yep
and this allows them to simply pay you
as opposed to you going after their
property
well it's the statute is worded oddly
the statute right now
says that the department shall recover
by way of adjusting current and future
grant amounts
and that's it it doesn't allow the
recipient
who especially if we discovered
resources they did not
report it does not allow the recipient
to simply pay back the department
um so we're correcting that
so if i could just follow up on that you
so if they may have committed fraud
that gives them the opportunity to pay
you back as opposed to being prosecuted
oh we would we would still take either
option
we could still um we could still
go after this case administratively or
we could refer it to law enforcement for
prosecution so that would not change
that process
would simply allow the individual again
whatever way that we pursued this case
would allow that individual to
pay back by way of money
cash a check to the department versus
simply saying
sure take it out of my future benefits
of which i'll be paid and i would note
you know
many of these people won't come back
onto benefits because we did discover
resources that were not reported
representative chase thank you and thank
you for taking my
question so just so i'm clear with this
these are
people is it like a good samaritan thing
where they're feeling guilty and say oh
geez i really have all these other
assets i haven't told you about
or are you actually investigating
someone that it just doesn't add up
properly
oh no we're in vet we have a unit here
called our special investigations unit
and we do investigate these cases and it
runs the gamut of
people who who we can't prove fraud and
who we simply say you were overpaid you
may have forgotten to tell us about that
individual who has a full-time job who
was living in your house with you
you may have forgotten to tell us about
all your resources but now
you were overpaid and you owe the state
back money
and then it will run all the way to the
other side of the gamut where someone
intentionally defrauded the department
and often those cases we do refer to
county attorneys
and they will go to court
okay thank you representative smith
representative smith you may be muted
representative smith oh thank you
i could not um unmute myself i'm sorry
um
if i could um and just further this
discussion
uh with two related questions can you
tell me how much money um you have
collected
in the last biennium for example
and can you tell me how much
you pay to operate your special
investigations unit
oh those are great questions i am going
to have to get back to you because i do
not want to lead you astray with um
estimated numbers i want to give you
exact numbers
that would be fine if you could get back
to the committee
um through the chair we would very much
appreciate that
and to reiterate your question you would
like that for the last buy
nem correct well i
said biennium because i thought that
those would be verifiable numbers
but if you have um knowing much more
about this than i do
if you have another way to accurately ex
demonstrate to the legislature that you
are
in fact collecting legitimate collecting
funds um
and this is how it cost you to close
those funds
that's interesting i just want the facts
ma'am
i i don't want uh to ask you a question
if you give me an
answer that in any way represents that
absolutely i will get that to the
committee this afternoon
uh thank you very much
representative thank you very much mr
chair thank you very much miss hennessy
my question is
related to representative smith which is
approximately how many people are
involved and how complicated operation
is it to administer
snap and the other benefits programs
like
i will say just several years ago i
happened to visit the hhs facility and
it was a
quite a large number of people actually
and appropriately so so if you
you can either look into that you can
either address that now or
or like while you're collecting the
other information you can collect that
information but
this gives a general idea at least if
possible thank you
sure i can certainly speak to staffing
we have
six fraud investigators we have
two individuals that run
claims so that's less um than an
investigation a case where we simply
um can assess how much needs to be paid
back
but to the department it's not a fraud
case uh we also have a paralegal
one part-time support staff and we just
hired an
administrator for the unit so um
you know it varies between staffing
between 10 to 12 people
total in the unit but in terms of fraud
investigators we have six
okay great thank you yeah so it's a it's
a it's a major
and continuously ongoing operation to
administer a program like this so
thanks
you have to unmute
no you're still muted still still muted
i'm sorry thank you
thank you mr chair and attorney
hennessey when you're when you're
talking about the recoupments
does this also include the nursing home
process
and the assessment of people going into
nursing homes
it does not representative this is
simply
cases with individuals who have been
identified to
have been overpaid their food stamps
their cash assistance
um child care supplements
those sorts of practices so no i'm not
including
any nursing home supplements in this
great thank you
and it's good to see you it's good to
see you too thank you
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
hennessey for taking my question
um i'm wondering what the process is
when the funds come from the feds
to the state and a person has overstated
um they have overpayments what's the
process for collection is that
strictly on the state or do the feds get
involved oh sure
we um well we do the investigations we
have strict oversight by fns
who oversees our food stamp program and
we would
um repay the feds i i'm not sure if
that's your question
the proportion to which they paid in to
the benefits that were overpaid
so we um we do allocate federal funds
back to the feds as well
in terms of them assisting we do have
monthly calls with them
they give us ideas they don't actually
have
investigators on the ground here with us
they do at the federal level if it's a
very big case which i haven't been
involved in
yet they certainly do have an oig their
own investigative services which they
could
take a case investigate a case maybe a
case that goes over state lines
something like that
thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you so much have a great afternoon
jeffrey phillips
good morning can you hear me you can
thank you mr chair and fellow house
members for allowing me to speak my name
is jeffrey phillips i'm the assistant
director of the division of fire
standards in
emergency medical services part of the
department of safety and i'm here to
provide testimony on section 9
relative to the emergency medical and
trauma data
services excuse me
starting around 2005 the state of new
hampshire implemented
a comprehensive patient care reporting
system which collects statewide
emergency medical services incident data
to date we have approximately over two
and a half million records
in the system this data is extremely
important
to the continued progression of
emergency medical services
by allowing our stakeholders to use new
hampshire specific data
to make decisions on how emergency
medical care is provided throughout the
state
this is used at both the local and state
level in the development and updating of
new medical procedures in which
ems providers are able to conduct
currently
the law limits the division's ability to
release the data for research purposes
only
this bill expands the ability to share
data not only for research purposes but
for analysis of the data as well
most recently during the copen 19
pandemic
division was working with contracting
with a third party vendor that would
allow
for real-time data analytics on copa19
calls
this functionality would have given the
state as well as the local first
responders real-time analysis of call
volumes coping 19 symptomatic patients
and potential coping 19 clusters
however this program stalled through the
department's inability to share data for
analytical purposes
additionally there are many other
opportunities to partner with state and
federal
agencies to enhance our knowledge
understanding and response in certain
areas of emergency
medical services one of these areas is a
response to opioid crisis
which all first responders in the state
have been dealing with on a daily basis
for many years
by sharing and linking ems data with
other sources
it will better equip the state and local
first responding agency to deal with
these
current with these current crisis
the new hampshire ems system relies
heavily on our own new hampshire data to
shape the future of ems within our state
the copa 19 pandemic has shown us that
emergency medical services within the
state
needs the ability to act quickly to
provide the best patient care to
residents of the state
this bill provides an avenue for the
department to explore different
mechanisms that will allow for the anal
analysis which will then provide the
ability to make sound
decisions backed by new hampshire data
additionally
when senator carson spoke about this
bill at the beginning
um during the the hearing i we did speak
with senator apprentice
in regards to the the proposed amendment
that the department was offering
um i think there might have been slight
a little bit confusion
the original bill was to amend the
current law
um we did confirm with senator prentiss
during that
during the meeting that there is no um
there's no amendment coming for this
portion um
in regards to from the department of
safety if anybody
has any questions i'll be more than
happy to answer them
there are questions
yeah yeah so so is this data
when it's shared is it anonymized anyway
what what's in the data that's being
shared
um it really depends on the request
very very infrequently we will
provide patient information for research
purposes is for
only health related research
most everything is all the personal
information is redacted and removed so
you you would get like uh incident type
the
the potential location um
the system that we're looking at using
would only it would aggregate
information at the county level
so nobody could get anything lower than
the county level
um but it really it depends on what the
request is
yes so in those cases where you are
sharing patient information with the
state is rare
what are what are the security
parameters that are around that
currently
uh so currently right now we go through
if somebody is requesting any patient
information it has to go through a
privacy committee that's part of the
ems trauma ems and trauma coordinating
board
and then it has to be authorized through
the commissioner department of safety
at that point there's a user agreement
that would be established in regards to
that only patient information can be
used for certain information
and at the completion of their research
all data must be destroyed
or returned back to the department
i guess if i could just follow up on
that as i read it
i don't see any prescription on
personal data here in the bill itself
you've indicated that you have some
practices but
um so and i don't have a off there there
is a portion of
153 that does speak about the privacy
committee
so 153 835 talks about the privacy
committee that has to be
authorized by the privacy committee um
i'm sorry i'm just um i
i can look into the rest of the 153
section that
does talk about it but there are
protection pro sorry protections in
regards to the
information we abide by all hip uh hipaa
regulations to make sure that
patient information is not disclosed
there are the questions
or mr phillips
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today thank you for your time
okay uh and i know that uh was mentioned
that uh
that margaret is it i'm pronouncing it
correctly
uh wang testified
quartz
[Music]
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is margaret huang
and i am the alternative dispute
resolution coordinator for the new
hampshire judicial branch
i'm testifying today in support of part
three
which will permit the office of
mediation and arbitration to establish
a quality assurance program rsa 490
e-2 authorizes the office to oversee the
development of alternative dispute
resolution programs
integral to this oversight is the
ability to monitor and evaluate
services provided by the office and
neutrals approved by the judicial branch
to provide alternative dispute
resolution services
this bill will codify the office's
current complaint practice
which is when the office receives a
complaint from a party
who has participated in a
court-connected adr program
the office investigates the complaint by
speaking to the other parties and the
mediator
the bill will provide those who choose
to engage with the court connected adr
program with notice that the other
parties and or
the mediator may share mediation related
information with the office
for the purposes of handling a complaint
in addition this section gives
permission for parties and mediator
to discuss quality assurance issues
while still maintaining the
confidentiality
otherwise afforded by law rule or order
thank you for your time and i'm happy to
answer any questions that you may have
are there any questions for uh as well
so yeah representative mclennan so
if you could just maybe give me an
example
of a situation where
you think that having this quality
assurance program
what are some of the difficulties that
you encounter that
would bring forth a need for this
thank you for that question um the
framework of confidentiality
is patchwork across different case types
for mediation
so having this part allows the office to
cite to a law
when speaking to parties in the neutral
as an allowance
for an exception to confidentiality but
only for the purposes
of quality assurance so for example
let's say that the office receives an
email from a party
that says that they don't believe that
the neutral
was um neutral
was neutral in this case um we would
reach out to the party and ask them
you know what happened during the
mediation um at that time we would ask
them if they would be willing to waive
confidentiality for themselves for the
purposes of investigating the complaint
um if they say yes then we will proceed
with the investigation
um sometimes neutrals and other parties
in the case
are concerned about confidentiality so
they having this part will allow the
office to cite to
a statute that says yes
for this very very limited circumstance
you are able to break confidentiality so
that we can
investigate um what happened in this
mediation
any other questions yes representative
rice
sorry um thank you thank you for taking
my question
so um for the mediation and arbitration
is
what would one of the instances be say
they were they felt coerced or
um threatened in some way how would
um that is a possibility it has not come
up
um since i've been head of the office
um you know sometimes it could be that
the mediator suggested something that a
party did not
like as an option um
sometimes it could be that there was a
problem with technology
that the mediator had trouble navigating
a platform
so those are some of the situations that
have come up
um since i've been the alternative
speed resolution coordinator and the
measures that we take
are commensurate with
the complaint that is received
great thank you very much you're welcome
thank you for your testimony thank you
earlier dennis goulet had his hand up i
noticed it isn't up anymore i don't know
if he wishes to testify or not
good morning mr chair members of the
committee um
my name is dennis goulet i am the
commissioner for the department of
information technology
and i'm here this morning to testify um
in favor of part eight
that language was requested
actually last session and ended up in in
on the bus legislation that didn't
proceed so we're we're
taking another bite at the apple um we
we feel this is important for a couple
reasons
one is that over time we've been working
to coordinate better with our political
subdivisions on cyber security
incidents which seem to be happening you
know quite regularly
so the first part of this bill talks
about um promulgating
suggested not required standards for
political subdivisions and the reason
for that is really to
begin to align and get uh folks on the
same page with respect to
how you would know whether you are your
cyber security posture
is good or not
the second part does require that
political subdivisions would report
a cyber security incident to the new
hampshire cyber
integration center and and the reason
for that is twofold
one is that we do connect to a lot of
these entities
either for law enforcement purposes
also for our for the clerks
to do motor vehicle registration so if
for example a
ransomware incident is happening at a
political subdivision which has happened
frequently we would like to know about
that as soon as possible so that we can
take steps to protect the state network
the second piece is that oftentimes
these entities don't really know what
resources exist
for them that could assist them
in the case of a cyber incident and the
faster you respond to a cyber incident
the better off you are so
we may be in position to point them in
the right direction once we know what's
occurring in that political subdivision
we have some examples where we've been
able to help communities
you know more quickly recover from a
cyber incident
now um i i we
senator rosenwald earlier mentioned an
amendment that had been placed in the
bill and that's the last sentence
that you see there in this section
and it was suggested to me that um i
inadvertently
misused um
legal um jargon the hold harmless
the intent there was that if if a um
if a political subdivision based on lack
of knowledge didn't report to us
we wouldn't penalize them in any way so
i have new language that's
that's much better that i would like to
ask this committee to consider
i can send that right along right after
this meeting it's essentially the same
thing what it says is that if a
community
fails to report there'll be no jeopardy
attached there's no
there's no penalty or anything like that
so it's a very simple switch out of the
last sentence one
one for another that's all my formal
testimony happy to answer any questions
any questions
and you're going to send that proposed
amendment to us or
send it to the committee yes i will
thank you
thank you thank you for your testimony
today
is there anyone else who'd like to
testify today on hospital 142.
if there are you can raise your hand if
you're in attendance
i see no other hands
therefore i'll declare the hearing on
house bill 143
quote
and that concludes our work for the day
unless there are any other issues that
anybody wants to raise
if not i just want to say i really don't
like these omnibus bills i
felt it was hard to follow and i'm
really like concerned that
i may have missed an important question
somewhere so i just thought i'd
voice my disagreement with this
i i i think there are many who share
your opinion
no i don't uh i don't think it's a good
way to do business
okay then i guess we see everybody uh
next tuesday morning at nine o'clock
and uh if i i do get the proposed
amendments and they're sent to me then
i'll send up
everybody okay
thank you everybody have a great week
thank you everybody have a great day
thank you